and sadiq khan joins me now thanks uh
uh being with us so so what is this plan
well we know from the evidence of the
chief scientific advisor and the chief
medical officer
that this virus is spreading
exponentially across all age groups
in fact in london we know unfortunately
uh that this virus is spreading across
our city
without the positive tests being shown
because testing in london
is still a mess as indeed it was back in
march so we're keen to avoid
is a second lockdown as we saw in march
and april
and we've come up with a package of
measures cross-party
with various london leaders additional
measures to slow down
the spread of the virus and basically
they're learning the lessons from the
northeast the north west and birmingham
for example
reducing transmissions in the community
by
having everyone wearing face masks not
just in public transport and in shorts
but in other public spaces
as well in hospitality for all staff as
well as
where possible for customers to wear
face coverings
for where possible uh there to be few
occasions
when the transmissions can be passed and
we've seen for example in the northeast
and the north west the hours
that pubs and bars are open have been
slightly reduced to slow down
the spread of the virus and the other
measures we've got as well and i'm
hoping
the prime minister will invite me as the
mayor along to the cobra meeting
and we can discuss in a grown-up manner
the additional measures we can take
to slow down the spread of the virus so
you want a curfew in london do you
on on restaurants and bars
and bars yeah the time doesn't matter
there's nothing magic about 10 p.m or 11
p.m
the issue is the amount of hours people
are spending together where they could
be asymptomatic
and the virus passes on by the way none
of this would be a problem
if there was proper testing taking place
what we actually need
is a fully functioning testing system
and a fully functioning
contact tracing system the challenge is
this here in london we know
that because the testing numbers have
gone down in the last two weeks because
they've been sent to other parts of the
country
although the numbers of positive cases
have gone down the indications are
the virus has gone up and in the absence
of a fully functioning testing system
or a contact tracing system we've got to
slow down
community transmissions this is what
happened exactly the same in march
where we delayed in implementing
measures which led to the need for
lockdown okay
but i don't quite get how this curbs the
spread i mean you're talking about
more people wearing masks in maybe more
settings and
and knocking a few hours off from bars
and
restaurants is there anything else that
you you've come up with with this plan
this whole package of measures i think
there's 15 different uh measures from
funerals to weddings to the way the rule
of six
works if your place of work isn't
covered secure
or if your means from getting to home to
work on a safe way
that we're encouraging people where
possible to work from
home there are other measures set out in
relation to what we can do
around care homes we do know for example
back in march april and may
there was a huge increase in positive
cases in kilms
which led to unfortunately uh huge
numbers of people losing their lives and
family still today being a brief so
it's a package of additional measures we
think can be taken to avoid the need
of a further lockdown in our city or
indeed across the country
you mentioned what's going on up north i
mean up north there's restrictions like
you know families not being allowed to
mingle with other families and
you know households having to just um
you know stay in side or where they
can't meet people
other families inside or outside are you
planning
that kind of thing for london
what we know in london is the way the
virus is spreading in our city
is slightly different how it's spreading
in other parts of the country
where there could be intergenerational
families so at the moment
the additional measures that the council
leaders and i have discussed with the
public health experts
isn't suggesting that households
shouldn't be visiting other households
as long as they respect the rule of six
in other words there shouldn't be more
than six people together
at any one time so you think the rule of
six is working do you i mean it's it's
only been a week or so but you think the
rule of six
is good enough do you
not by itself no and that's why we're
suggesting the additional measures
what's quite clear
in relation to the number of the metrics
we have we've seen not just calls to 111
calls to gps hospital admissions and
other measures as well going
up over the last few weeks it's quite
clear that the rule of six by itself
isn't sufficiently slowing down the
virus spreading
that's why we're suggesting the
additional measures tomorrow to the
prime minister and the government
um so you're not saying that restaurants
and bars should close at 10 pm
necessarily then what is the limitation
you're suggesting on restaurants and
bars
it's worth just reminding your viewers
why tempium was suggested
it was to reduce the amount of hours
people spent with each other
inadvertently passing the virus on
so we are suggesting as one of the
measures to reduce the amount of time
it's
that the virus is passed on when it's
asymptomatic and when there are so few
tests
hopefully when the numbers of tests in
london increases
when we have a fully functioning test
system the hours can be increased again
as they've been done over the course of
the month of august
we now know unfortunately because of the
increased socialization during august
that could be one of the reasons why
there's been an increase
in the covet cases in london and indeed
across the country sort of limitation on
hours are you talking about
can you be a bit more specific
and we think one of the things that we
think may work is in some parts of a
country we've seen
a 10 p.m time and there's nothing magic
about 10 pm
it's simply reducing the amount of hours
people may spend with each other
passing the virus on okay i mean you
know the
up north i've just come i've been up
north for the last uh end of last week
and
the hospitality industry is deeply
worried about it i mean
you are the mayor of one of europe's
great cities
which is many people would say is
creaking to a halt
um do you have concern about the
casualties
that could be involved economically and
you know
as regards mental health
absolutely i think the best way to avoid
an economic crisis and to compound the
mental health crisis
is to do with a public health crisis
it's inextricably
linked it's not one or the other i'm
really concerned
about central london about the central
activity zone
about canary wharf about footfall the
impact on
transport for london and public
transport i'm equally concerned
about the virus bred in fast level that
led to the chief scientific advisor
and the chief medical officer advising
that in the middle of a
totally some people would say you should
be priority getting london going again
going again well my priority is to do
more than one thing at a time
a health crisis is leading to an
economic crisis
which has led to a mental health crisis
the way to avoid the virus spreading
even
faster is to take these additional
measures the way to do that by the way
is for us to get around the table as
grown-ups to discuss some of the
experiences you've just talked about
in the northeast the north west with not
just the north east the northwest but
with
the leaders of scotland wells northern
ireland and the prime minister
at a cobra meeting if not physically but
virtually that's what we should be doing
okay and just in a word um do you think
you'll be invited to cobra yes or no
in a word
uh i hope so that's a sensible thing to
do okay thanks very much indeed